how are you Jeff fantastic I was also
surprised by the mission game I think it
just goes to show you that offense is
now in college football if you can run
like Ohio State can you just have a
better advantage over defense I mean I
just look like Ohio State was quicker
faster especially in offense and
Michigan wasn't defense well they're
also a little bit deeper I guess I mean
some of these running backs that coming
out of the backfield there's like 3/4 of
them you know and Michigan does have
them too I just
they just weren't they weren't as good
on this day that's it is that simple
it's that simple and Haskins is terrific
I mean Haskins came off the bench when
they Michigan was stopping JT Barrett
last year and essentially won that game
to Jeff but I mean and I guess this is
why we're seeing more of this type of
stuff in the NFL right yeah because
offenses seem to be ahead if it's
there's still obviously a purpose and
plenty of defense I think that we've
seen that through the history of sports
or Alabama still plays great defense
obviously on to it but even in the NFL
you know the chiefs and rams
shoot out whatever that was a week ago
those teams don't play enough defense in
my opinion to make a big stop in a
playoff game a Super Bowl setting you
have to place some Sun with the defense
to win in my opinion playoff games and
cause football playoff games in the NFL
especially a high school in Super Bowl
last year but it came down to Brandon
Graham making a play against a really
good guard and Shaq Mason you have to be
able to make plays at times and if you
can't rush the passer and you can't even
stop the pass at all you really have no
chance when it comes to well Jeff
Schwartz here on the Rich Eisen show
what what happened with the Giants in
the second half yesterday how does say
Quan got a say Quan stay on the
sidelines like that I'm not even that
[Music]
upset about that I mean I was watching
the game and I thought it was odd too
but Odell Beckham he made it clear
afterwards they shot got him the ball 20
times
I mean rich mean you could to the suit
up for the Eagles in the secondary but
ended I game they wore there's no one
left they had no one left to play
secondary for them and how you don't
attack
uh the entire game in their secondary
was beyond me the first half I tweeted
said the giant looked like a very
competent offense they were formation
diverse they were finding ways to get
the ball too tight and his hands in
hotels hands at Barclays and and the
second half they went away from doing
that and look the Eagles as bad as
they've been at times on defense they
can't stop the run decent mouse I wasn't
that upset to the Giants away from the
run game I was upset they were away from
the pass game because that's what you go
for terrible at you have Hotel Beckham
giving the ball you know here Jalen
Ramsey we played against a weak one Oh
tell her ten catches you play this guys
we did last night we read off the names
of the Eagles secondary players you
start a lot of site I don't know who
they are and I saw that I felt very
closely like give the ball to look
outside Odell fed that after the game I
thought that was appropriate to say so
not upset about the sake horn Barkley it
would have been nice
I won't ride the football but the ball
should have been with dentals hands wave
loss in that game and so how concerned
about the Steelers should we be Jeff
that's now two games in row they pulled
one out of there you know what in
Jacksonville and then yesterday Denver
really put it to him I mean they really
it's a tough place to play and win
obviously and Thanksgiving weekend and
and Denver really seems to have slowed
them down
I mean 550 yards on offense they just
did convert what it matter which is
important right I mean I'm not
overlooking that that part of that but
you know you have a team in Pittsburgh
who move the ball fine all game they
just fumbled out the back of the end
zone which I despised that rule it's one
of NFL's worst role defended that that
they should in my opinion he to I I
don't think that they should punish the
defense by giving the ball back to the
offense I think that that defense should
get the ball at the spot so they should
get the ball to Javier line there you
know it should be turnover still but not
to the point because if you give the
ball back to your office at that spot if
then basically gates the defense making
employ like parks made the tackle on
gimbals
and and Grimble I should say and
to me to me you shouldn't give the ball
to the defense Jeff because had had the
ball been fumbled out at the half yard
line the Steelers we've been able to
keep the ball at the half the yard line
just because it rolled a few more inches
of real estate into the end zone should
not now make it the ball in the hands of
the defense what they should do is it
should be like a reverse touch back and
move the ball back to the 24
you know first intent or whatever the
down and distance was from the 20 just
that's a penalty I don't lose the ball
might you just lose field position maybe
if that's the way it works okay I'll
tell you I disagree a tad on that
because we treat the goal line
differently when we do other points the
field right if you cross the goal on its
own ball it's a touchdown it's not that
way for a first I like there's just
different rules we have at the goal one
that we do at the rest of the field I do
ever kind of like your idea bringing the
ball back and I had a little article in
this I propose that you give the ball
back to the offense but they lose it
down so basically it gets a little bit
of punish on blowing out the back of the
end zone losses on social into defense I
gotta guess a little bit of love for
maintenance employees but back to Susan
I'm not terribly worried I mean well
yeah Denver is a hard place to play
first of all Denver was about themselves
are just people Chargers Denver has
actually a pretty decent schedule down
the stretch they could kind of scare
teams to make money making a wild card
I'm not necessary by the Steelers
they'll be fine ok Jeff Schwartz here on
the Rich Eisen show ask him the poll
question over there Christopher go for
it yeah Jeff who's been the biggest
disappointment in 2018 most
disappointing team Giants Falcons
Jaguars
Packers Raiders I can't imagine that
this anyone would vote for anyone other
than the Jaguars a lot of people we had
Greg Jennings on earlier he said it was
the Packers where does that where did
the Jaguars rank right there Jaguars are
second at 31% Green Bay first 38 yeah I
would choose the Jaguars to man I
thought that there was no way that this
young up-and-coming team would take a
step back and I even with Blake bortles
this quarterback
he performed well enough when the chips
were down last year I thought that they
that they would take take the similar
path it's been terrible it's been awful
really
and it's and as they're running back
throwing down on the sidelines with
bills players I you know when I was in
the game and came off the basket to
fight on that play
oh it's for sure Jackie look the the
Packers there were signs this was coming
in my opinion you know you have Rogers
coming off of injury but just the
offense in general it's been stagnant
for a couple years now what they doing
offensive and it's not to come to them
and I'm not surprised it feels like the
offense is now has kind of passed up
McCarthy is they went up their wide
receivers a lot of static formations
they put two guys on one side three guys
on one side they don't mean very much if
I spread out to and they say wide
receivers you get open and we'll fight
and we'll find you a lot of offenses now
use formations and personnel groupings
and they use stacks and motions and
shifts to get guys open to get them good
releases and find spots in the zone to
throw and they don't do that that's why
Rodgers is often also rhythm so I said
throw relating it down there's never an
easy throw in the Packers offense
compared to when you see these other
offenses that are function of the high
levels obvious time for McCarthy go plus
with the fourth down decision-making
process it doesn't know when to go for
it when not to calls it dodge yesterday
I just I think it's time it's run its
course get someone else in for Rogers
and they Jeff Schwartz here on the Rich
Eisen show I can't I can't dispute what
you just said I mean that dive to on
Aaron you know the wrong Aaron carried
the ball you know I think you go just
one yard not even I hate I hate the
floor I hate the full-back dive I hate
to dive it's so it's that a goal I'm
saying are my two least favorite plays
if you're gonna if you're gonna give a
dive to someone just to a quarterback
sneak the quarterback is right there
already to snap the ball and go forward
a dive takes too long to take too long
and you end up having a wide receiver
trying to block a safety at all for
safety Harrison Schmitt just meet the
ball who's gonna do that - same blocking
for the office go on just keep the ball
last one for you what you think of Baker
Mayfield's comments about
why he didn't give Healy the bro hug he
didn't even he didn't even give him the
courtesy of the bro hug he just extended
the arm because he'll join the you know
a team that they're playing twice now
um well he might be the first to get
fired twice in the same season I'm
looking forward to making some history
this year and imagine um I mean come on
he's offensive coach you're hired
because of defense I guess they allow
300 Russian guards and looked
unpreparedness Lamar Jackson the Browns
for 28 points in the first half yeah the
second half was better okay you know the
school basically our defense in the
second half from a player's perspective
I totally get where Baker's coming from
I don't begrudge you for taking another
job he was fired it's really think of
jogging it was odd for him to go so
quickly to a division opponent a week or
two after he was fired it does feel like
that was a player I would feel like
there was like there was some revenge oh
he wanted to go to the Bengals to beat
the Browns twice fired right I mean it's
not like I don't I'm I get it I get both
sides of it I get you Jackson wanted to
work I'm just telling you that I get
what Baker made sure was coming from I
was through the same line in the locker
room
it's my coach my head coach not at the
district tell us no one else okay is it
very rare that we see this head coach
it's fired goes to a division rival two
weeks before they play that team and
coaching the opposite side of the ball
that he coached his entire career so
you're taking offensive guy putting him
on defense and basically saying huge
tell us everything you know about the
Browns offense so you try to stop them
off you didn't work at all yesterday I
mean if you gave me if I gave you an
option and this is amazing I'm asking
this question that's even a legit one
which for six and one team has a better
chance of making a playoffs with a where
the wildcards succeed is six and five
same thing in the AFC in the NFC the
Browns with Baker Mayfield or Aaron
Rodgers in the Packers oh this question
means fact well they're bought the same
record they both have us the similar
issue which is they're not going to win
their division but they have the ability
to make a wild card because the team
that's in the six seat is just six and
five a game and a half in front of them
well the Browns are at the Texans at the
Broncos at the Ravens that's going to be
difficult but the Packers are over six
on the road this year so they have more
home games going down the stretch I
would I would lean with the Packers
still because they have Aaron Rodgers
they've done it before and like I said
they have three home games coming down
the stretch and they're at the Jets is
one of their away game so I feel like
the Packers are still the answer here
the brown still got to prove it to me
make the playoffs before I can crown you
as well I'm not saying they're going to
but I'm you know this is this is a total
1,000% sports talk radio question Jeff I
mean you know
but the fact that you said it's not well
I'm going with Aaron Rodgers over Baker
Mayfield you went scheduled on me you
know just says I think everything that
uh needs weight that's the way I am I'm
not going to put my neck on the line I
dressed for the Browns over the Packers
right now well done Jeff appreciate the
chat we'll chat again soon always enjoy
all right warts I follow them on Twitter
it's je o FF Schwartz it's a good follow
really good follow the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience